so in Megan looking for corporate
sponsors what's the best way to approach
someone is that a phone call is it an
email well again this isn't necessarily
my world it's I've been learning a lot
from Lindsey Roe who's a publicist but
really what I've noticed and and from
watching her is that the best way to
approach at least at this point is an
email just a very general very nice
email and to really try to forge your
when you're when you're formulating this
email you know know what company you're
you are pitching to you know know what
they can bring to the table or what you
would want them to bring to the table
but also pitch the story like in our
case it's very much of like a you know
emotional touchy-feely kind of movie and
so we really push that you know getting
involved with this would really you know
help this family so much it did and
really with the case of RAM our outreach
in the boat I mean we did change his
family's life forever and so it really
meant a lot to us and it meant a lot to
that company too and um the people that
came and representatives everybody
involved and so I think kind of pushing
how the organization or the company can
what they can get out of it you know and
in terms of whatever your social action
subject is but in terms of ours we're
really going after organizations that
that already help Filipinos you know
people that are medical based or you
know something that kind of had
something to do with the subject are
already but really I think what works is
also is to send out as many emails as
possible find as many people that you
can to pitch this you know one or two is
not gonna cut it you know like I said I
think Lindsey sent out 25 of these
emails pitch emails to 25 different
companies and we got one to respond so I
think that's also the important factor
to keep in mind is that you gotta you
know throw a lotta bait out there before
someone's going to respond but um you
know once one responded and then you go
and you pitch to other or organizations
and other corporations that you want to
get to come on for you know in our case
we were trying to find um flip-flop
partners and tractor partners and lots
of different kinds of things to help the
families that are featured a
and then you get to say well this
organization has already signed up but
these these are our other partners and
then be able to go to your website see
the photos from when we gave the boat to
them and the tears and you know all that
kind of thing and had links to Ramar
outreach so that the the next level of
corporate sponsors or people that were
pitching to have somewhere to go to see
that there are other people who have
already invested in you other
organizations that have invested in you
so it's definitely like I said in the
interview don't be afraid to ask just be
nice and be friendly and you know push
your project he's passionate as possible
and really show the organization that
they can get something out of it too
it's a mutual partnership how long do
you make this email cuz that sometimes
that's always the weird part like do you
hit them with all the good stuff or do
you just do a feeler or like I'm always
wondering how long the email should be
yeah I think it kind of varies in terms
of like how I'm you know in depth your
project is but for ours it was it was
longer than what I would think to be
honest like the the email that she was
sending out but what it did in a way was
bullet point alt like like you were
saying kind of giving all the good stuff
now you want it to all be in there in a
way that is intriguing and exciting but
also will get them to your website
because that's ultimately where you want
them to go you know it's very much like
Twitter or Facebook that you're like hey
check this out go here and you'll really
try to get people to go somewhere else
then that one original platform so I
think the the goal is is to get make
yourself sound really awesome you know
smoke and mirrors all the way but is to
get that to get enough on the page for
the reader to go back to your website
yeah would you say you're a planner I
mean do you have a 5-10 year goal kind
of mapped out or are you more sort of
fatalistic and you think oh whatever
happens happens and I'm gonna keep doing
what I love to do no definitely
definitely plan oriented definitely have
a five have a 10 year plan you know I
I'm living it besides the whole living
to paycheck to paycheck which is awesome
I'm on that path
you know I'm not as far as I would like
to be but the goal is to shoot a feature
film by the time I'm 30 and so I that's
happens so that's really exciting and
it's kind of turned into a bunch of
other things that are going toward the
five-year plan than ten year plan and
all that jazz so I think it's um I think
if you're if you're going to be
competitive in this field you have to be
plan oriented it's it's hard I think to
be like well you know to or at least for
me maybe it's because of my control
issues but you know I think that having
aiming towards something is really nice
you know this is nice to have do you
write these goals down or they're
they're all up in the computer upside
you'll write them down but I do remember
those exercises in elementary school
where you're supposed to be writing your
goals down and stuff um but um but I do
I do have them they are in my head and
there are things that um and even though
even I think it's also important to have
the short-term goals to like when your
project oriented and to be competitive
in this field you need to have those
little small goals those are all written
down I mean like calendars out the wazoo
you know I mean it's just they're sticky
notes all over the place so I think um
you know it's it's definitely good to
have little short-term goals that lead
to the bigger goal and then you can see
that something's happening you see that
you're moving forward it's not just like
oh my god I haven't got to that
unobtainable goal yet you know I did
this this and this and it's leading me
towards that and so I think that has
really helped me kind of keep this like
upbeat like it's gonna happen you know
it's definitely gonna happen you guys
have all these little goals that I can
check off the list you know it's like
okay I was on film courage today that
was one of the goals so like now I get
to check it off so I think being able to
have those little things and like
leaning towards we're gonna submit to
Sundance in September that's what's
gonna happen we're getting we're gonna
finish this film you know and so I think
it kind behind - when you're kind of
running the show you know everyone's
like okay it's September this is we have
to do this you know so it being goal
oriented I think it's very important
pressure
and you have a very upbeat attitude
which is great and it shows but do you
ever have down days or at night is it
scary I know for me sometimes at night
it's like I start focusing on stuff I'm
worried about do you do that yeah yeah
and I think I think we all have our
insecurities and I think that it is
extremely hard to be up P and passionate
and like yes hundred percent all the
time and so but what does have you do
get burned out you do get to the point
where you like you know you went so far
down a path and it didn't pay off and
it's so incredibly frustrating and so
you think like time wasted and all that
those kind of negative thoughts start
piling in and you know for me at least
it's like I have a little mini freakout
and then I'm like fine
and then I move on you know and that's
how it's always been so it's kind of
like this crazy emotional you know
roller coaster and I think a lot of
filmmakers and artists can agree with me
you guys come on but it's like
definitely something that it's um it's a
battle you know it's a battle to keep
yourself from falling into that like
what was me kind of tight place you know
and especially going to like an art
school and being so heavily involved at
the community here and watching other
people going off when living your dreams
you know I hear a lot of you know fellow
filmmakers kind of falling prey to that
you know being jealous or you know
letting themselves feel jealous because
of this other thing and instead I pushed
all that out of my mind and I'm like
super happy for so me and my friends
that I went to college with and
everyone's really a lot of us are really
living the dream which is really great
and so I find it more now inspirational
that so many of my friends have gone
this far and seeing and knowing the
people that you met in college and it's
like or that I've met out here and
you're like that that person's going
there doing something and then they do
and so it's great to hear other people
being like well you're do like that too
and some on alright that that makes me
feel like I'm on the right path that
makes me feel like I'm doing the right
thing and you know having like I said
having the goals being able to check
things off the list and that a lot of
those things really keep me try to keep
me I'll be being involved in a bunch of
different creative creative endeavors
keeps me passionate about stuff you know
getting my hands wet and a bunch of
different things
so I think that really keeps me up being
excited about stuff you know and I think
that's interesting what you brought up
about being jealous because there is
this perception that somebody that's
doing so much like you are and has just
you know great photos online and great
trailers and then it's beautiful and on
top of it it seems like it's just so
easy and then it's so easy to like oh
well you know she has it so good and how
do you think if there are other people
out there that may be feeling that that
fall prey to that envy what's the best
advice for that person so that they know
that it's not as easy as it looks and
and yeah I mean I know it's kind of a
weird question but I think a lot of
people you know you see them on YouTube
where you see them on message boards or
whatever and they're in there bashing
and katherine heigl are just different
people and it seems like i don't know
seems easy to bash that person but i'm
sure it's not easy for that person
that's in the limelight there how would
you what would you recommend to those
sort of that haterade that comes in well
I think if you fall prey to like like
you know jealousy or kind of feeling
like like what you just said is that you
you begin to lose the community that you
were a part of in the first place or
that you're trying to be a part of and
so you know going back to like Twitter
and Facebook and all of my friends from
college and then I've been out here you
know like it's a community and what you
put into is what you get out of it and
you have to be involved you have to
support everybody you cannot be jealous
in like these silly ways it's like you
need to see well that person is doing
something really cool I have a similar
interest maybe we can hook up and do
something together you know especially
since I started getting out there was so
much of the social networking I've had
so many of my classmates come to me and
ask me like whoa I've been seeing all
the stuff that you're doing on Facebook
what are you doing like how did you do
this and I was like I got on Facebook
I'm on Twitter and Facebook every day
you know and just doing it and like you
know they're doing projects too and a
lot of a lot of my classmates are all
we're all in this kind of paralleling
like getting out of the the short-form
world trying to get into the future
world that kind of stuff but where I'm
different was that I took I accepted
that social networking is just a part of
filmmaking now and so it's really
exciting to like kind of reconnect with
a lot of my especially East Coast
friends that I went to school with and
should be like hey man like if you put
yourself out
there I will tweet and Facebook the
out of it like just put it out there I
don't know your doing anything you know
if you tell me that you're doing
something I see that you're doing
something I will support you
wholeheartedly you know because that's
how it has to be filmmaking is so
freakin hard like being an artist is so
incredibly hard we cannot like turn on
each other we cannot be jealous we have
to support everybody so that it isn't
vindictive and it isn't you know it's
it's definitely like a love relationship
that everybody's working and I hope that
that is that I can live up to this
ridiculous you know a goal that I'm
trying to give that it is hard and I'm
not gonna say that it doesn't happen to
me too you know like I find myself being
jealous of others of others success but
I think that it's important like I said
to realize that you know you should be
used as motivation and and you know or
motivation to hook up with that person
and tell them I did a good job or help
them tweet it or you know whatever it is
and it's yeah and I absolutely love
being part of this community for that
very